new at 10 a Danville man said he was
punched repeatedly in the face by a
driver who wanted his Parking Spot It
Happened outside the Costco on Fostoria
Fostoria Way that's where we find ktvu's
Alyssa Harrington she spoke with the
victim tonight about what happened
Alyssa how's he doing
that's right you know I got a chance to
sit down with him today he has two black
eyes a sore shoulder some by the way
people say black black eyes it just
sounds like he has two black guys
about black ice
when it when it snows and rains and then
on the asphalt there's like black eyes
everywhere guys tonight beware of black
guys all over the roads
it may lead to your and it's just black
guys
be careful I do be scared of black ice
though
upstairs
you never slipped on black ice
absolutely [__] my [__] up yeah I
think since I know I [__] my [__] yo
that is what since you know me you [__]
your [__] up what
should never be in the same sentence
foreign
basically because the asphalt is already
pretty dark color when it rains in cold
places there's a thin layer of ice
that's almost invisible you can just see
the asphalt through you think so people
just slip on it or like Drive everything
you think it's the ground yeah it ain't
it's black guys
it's everywhere and it [__] your [__]
up yeah the number of times I [__] got
messed up
I want to warn you that some of the
images you will see in this story are
graphic
feeling like I got run over by a
steamroller
my whole body is sore Craig Blackburn
he was
Blackburn got black ass
I'm juvenile
[__] you whoa that's personal
I'm from they came from where it came
from okay that came from deep inside
juvenile
leave a comment below how juvenile am I
let's carry on
Costco parking lot Sunday during an
argument over a parking spot this
happened just before 11 30 a.m at the
location on Fostoria Way Blackburn said
he had just finished shopping and was
loading up his car while eating a Costco
hot dog this guy's sitting in his car
and
says some things to me about my weight
in eating a hot dog and he wanted my
parking spot and told me to hurry up and
I told him to go find another spot
there's a lot of birds chirping in the
back man yeah yeah yeah the birds are
saying this thing is lying we going on
tour we coming to cities near you we
want to see you [__] face to
face where you at we gonna be doing
shows awesome well this summer we're
doing three shows we're doing Detroit
Pittsburgh and Washington DC but
afterwards we were going to England
we're going to be going all across
America Asia so if you want to get
tickets make sure you guys go to the
website all right put your name so we
can email you as soon as those tickets
come out for your area we won't bombard
you with nothing else okay I promise
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys Blackburn
said the driver wouldn't move other
people started honking and the situation
escalated he was looking for a fight the
driver finally parked somewhere else but
came back to find Blackburn as he was in
his car getting ready to leave he
reached in and grabbed my sunglasses and
threw him on the ground so I got out of
the car and I didn't have a chance to do
anything he just attacked me and
I fell down hit my knee oh my God you
did more than hits your knee
your [__] is oh [__] up true
you look you came out of a blender I
mean I think the thing that's most
bruised in all this is your pride oh
yeah I suspect
nobody wants to get beat while eating a
hot dog nobody wants to get beaten but
nobody wants proof that they got beat
see
if an ass beating happens in the woods
and nobody's there to witness it did it
really happen that's what I'm saying
I'm just saying I
know taking an L in front of my girl my
whole family and having to walk around
having to constantly be reminded of that
if it's me imma just lie a bear attacks
me where downtown so next question
he got [__] this can't be me ain't no
way I don't ever want to be a grandpa
getting my ass be like you got [__]
Blackburn was treated at the scene and
then taken by ambulance to the hospital
I was in the hospital there for about
six hours
got a CAT scan and a
about 10 or 15 X-rays and I've got
hemorrhaging in this eye I reached out
to the Danville Police Chief who sent my
request to the town of danville's public
information officer she confirmed
officers were called to this incident
and said no arrests were made the email
said
currently under investigation so what do
you guys think happened to the person
who attacked him what do you think
he claimed it was unprovoked the
prosecutor reviewed the evidence and it
was not unprovoked all right so here's
what's happening
the white vehicle the SUV belongs to
Blackburn the person whose face you saw
got [__] up now the other individual
who's in the who's in the white car that
is the person that supposedly attacked
Mr Blackburn now you see him here at
first he's waiting for the parking spot
but Mr Blackburn's refusing to give it
to him at one point someone else pulls
out of their spine they say hey man you
can have my place and he says no that
some words are exchanged between Mr
Blackburn the guy in the white car the
guy in the white car rather than taking
the parking spot that someone else had
offered decides to drive off to a
different part of the lot and park over
there
now what ends up happening is that as
the guy gets out of his car to go to the
store right and mind you at this time Mr
Blackburn has already pulled out with
his SUV and is leaving the parking lot
Mr Blackburn decides to do a U-turn come
back to where the guy is now walking on
foot and exchange some words and that's
when all hell breaks loose the dude
pulls him out of the car and [__] him
up
and then through all of this after the
prosecutor reviewed the evidence and the
police investigator they decides not to
press charges because they said Mr
Blackburn could have left at multiple
points he decided to circle around and
instigate and now his [__] ass want to
be a little not today [__] the
video shows Blackburn driving into a
separate row of the parking lot during
which he approaches the other man now
outside of his white sedan so he went
after him twice what I know is the
police decided not to press charges
because they said this man was he came
back you
you came back
right there on the second clip this
[__] came from here so you won't
he circled around he circled around to
come find him and then instigate the
situation the cop said bruh that's all
you
I've seen a lot of PL a lot of cases
that this happened where the police is
like yeah but why didn't you leave
like I might even go to court with that
yeah because you're wasting everybody's
time yeah you could have left yeah you
came back to look for it I don't think
you necessarily have the obligation to
leave it does make no no
he didn't could have left he left and he
turned around no you [__] around and
you came back and you didn't just come
back and stare you said some things the
way you're telling the story you made it
sound like I told him leave I know you
didn't just say that I know this man
didn't just get mad because you refused
to give him his parking spot you all
exchanged words y'all exchange enough
words and he and you had your parking
spot he left he went about his day you
circled back to come find him so the
initial video he paints himself to be of
him like he didn't do nothing and that's
why I say don't believe her don't
believe him believe facts and evidence
okay because people are gonna paint
themselves as a victim there's not a
woman there's not nothing like that this
man got up here and said it was
unprovoked you can clearly see from the
footage that is a flat lie it's a
different thing if he was in the parking
spot and the man came out and they
started fighting because that's wrong
but you went looking for him twice and
from the comfort of your vehicle he was
acting really Brave I I don't think it's
okay to beat old people I also don't
think all people should think they can
act and say and do whatever the [__]
they want just because they're old and
fragile especially not when you're in a
vehicle and you come at somebody who's
on the foot me not doing that I don't
care how old you are I don't care how
old you are I don't care who you are I
don't care what if you [__] around and
you find out to me it's just Tuesday
Morning Hey listen at your age you
should know better
they say youth is wasted on the young
sometimes wisdom is wasted on the old
especially knowing how fragile your body
is that's a oops you just got reminded
that all right listen look I'm not this
is not the situation I would ever be
involved in one but two I just don't
feel any sympathy for this old man I
don't I don't listen pop pop and you
don't even know what he said now that
he's live I believe this man probably
said the most foul things in the world
because the way he lying right now I bet
you he said things to really antagonize
that man and the police decide not to
charge good you know this one time while
they in the police did their job and
they said [__] you you start this
situation you deal with it good luck in
the hospital stupid and good I don't
feel no sympathy from anything else no
hey
not when people when people look like
around when people look for things and
then the things happen to them I'm like
what do you want me to say bruh what do
you want me to say what do you want me
to say if I come to find out he's like
yo yo come here and then you
know those women who started altercation
and they start crying no sympathy
you want to kiss you go get it